they insisted the government's care home
covered rules and led to their father's
deaths
today
two high court judges agreed
i have lost precious years with my
wonderful dad
i left him fit well and happy on the
22nd of march 2020 when his home went
into lockdown
he should have been safe and protected
but i never saw or spoke to him again
donald harris died in may 2020 after an
outbreak in his care home michael gibson
was also a care home resident he died
aged 88 on the 3rd of april 2020
he was a kind of very gentle man two
among some 20 000 deaths caused by the
unlawful action of the british
government
i've been disgusted by by the constant
denial that anything was done wrong the
constant claims that they handle the
pandemic so well you know we've had a
massive death toll in this country
the judgment is damning it says
those drafting the policy simply failed
to take the risk into account
decisions in april 2020 meant there was
a significant delay at a critical period
and the policy was irrational in failing
to advise
that an asymptomatic patient should be
kept apart from other residents
the judgment will bring relief and a
sense of justice for faye harrison dr
kathy gardner and for tens of thousands
of affected families it also sets a
marker for future government
action on emerging health crisis but it
also for the first time holds the
government to account ahead of any
covert inquiry
both women have called on the prime
minister to resign the thing that we
didn't know in particular uh mr speaker
was
that kovit could be transmitted
asymptomatically in the way that it was
this care home in milton keynes knows to
its cost the direct result of the
government's failure
having to
to learn
on the run as to how to fight this how
to manage the the risks
what we need to do
um
it it was incredibly trying incredibly
challenging um you know the fact that so
many care homes are still up still
running um so many of our vulnerable
residents have lived through it is a
huge testament to the hard work of the
the people that work in these homes
the traumas suffered by care home
residents their families and the staff
who care for them has left deep scars
they can take small comfort
from knowing they are not to blame
ashish joshi sky news
in central london